they sincerely believe that it's their
patriotic duty to stop these I think his
phrase was these or here today gone
tomorrow politicians from doing their
sort of crazy schemes immigration is a
very good example of this because it is
an issue on which the same promise is
made by success I know it's amazing and
then nothing gets done there's this
building rage and it's coming out in all
sorts of unpleasant ways but it's done
in the name of compassion I think that
is basically the the central kind of
theme of of almost everything that's
going
wrong Steve last time I was in the US
you and I met yeah uh we went for a
drink ended up being 10
drinks minimum minimum we had a great
time and you were telling me some horror
stories about why the British government
can't get anything done so I thought you
were going to start with the horror
story of how we tried to get that drink
and there was some like do you remember
there was an amazingly bureaucratic
person in that bar where where it was
Salt Lake City wasn't it it was
wonderful felt like being back in the UK
I know it's just ridiculous this endless
sort of like no you can't sit there and
sit there but it's a very good segue
into the story of the bureaucracy in the
uh in the British government yeah that
was the sort of thing that really was an
eyeopener you hear before you know I've
been involved in politics before then
and and you know anyone who reads the
pre you hear about the bureaucracy and
the Civil Service and and people who had
worked in government including Tony
Blair um who I'd met before the election
in 2010 when David Cameron became prime
minister and I was working for David
Cameron and in preparing for that time I
went to see Tony Blair to get his advice
you know he'd been prime minister and so
you know it was useful to learn and he
warned about the bureaucracy and that
was that was amazing to hear from him
what he said I don't I I don't want to
misquote him so these don't necessarily
quotes but he said and it was a long
time ago I mean it was over 10 years ago
but he said that don't he said don't I
remember he said don't
underestimate how strong the feeling is
on the part of the senior civil servants
that they sincerely believe that it's
their patriotic duty to stop these I
think his phrase was these or here today
gone tomorrow politicians from doing
their sort of crazy schemes and that
they are the guardians of National
interest don't that that is sincerely
what they think and you got to
understand that before you go in so that
was really that was the first kind of
really
um that was an eye opener actually
coming from him um but then when you get
there I mean it's it was just I mean
there's so many aspects to it but the
but the but the most interesting thing I
think maybe let's start with this which
was where I really started to dive into
exactly what was going on was pretty
soon I guess I don't know a couple of
months into the government and remember
it was a coalition government and in a
way that was really interesting because
it wasn't like normal where a party
would have a Manifesto and they run in
the election and they win and then they
sort of kind of do what they want
there's no
requirement um to do everything you say
you're going to do in fact a lot of
Voters get pissed off because they say
the governments don't do what they say
they're going to do this was really
interestingly
in that uh the conservative party that I
David Cameron was the leader and we
didn't get an overall majority so he
wanted to do a proper coalition
government with the liberal Democrats
and he and like a really longlasting one
he didn't want it just to be a kind of
shortterm will you vote for this bill
with us or whatever it was like I want
to sit down and negotiate an agreement
about what we would do as a kind of
coalition government for the five years
of a parliamentary term and that was
really interesting hadn't really been
done before and so it was hammered out
and we had this document and actually
you know like unusual for a government
we had a plan for what we were going to
do and it had been agreed and it was
called the Coalition agreement and we
published it so you think well that's
great because now we have a set of
commitments that we've
negotiated and that's the plan for what
we're going to do and pretty soon it was
it was just this interesting Revelation
where we became aware of the government
announcing things sometimes you just
hear them on the media which we either
weren't aware of or didn't really agree
with and it was just this interesting
phenomenon where you think well hang on
a second we are the government and so
what's going on here and so I I was I
was just interested in that process and
so our team in 10 Downing Street we did
a little analysis of the all the
different things that the government was
doing over the period of it's about a
week I think we took all the
announcements and some of them are big
and some of are small and they're all
done through this process called um I
think it's request for policy approval
or policy clearance where the ministers
write to their colleague the cabinet
committees and say I want to do this I'm
the education secretary I want to make
this change to how schools are run or
whatever and if no one objects it goes
ahead and that's really how it all works
and then we looked at all of that over a
certain period and said well how much of
that is actually implementing the
Coalition agreement the actual thing
we're supposed to be doing and over the
course of whatever the period we were
looking at the answer was 30% so 30% of
what the government was doing was
implementing what it supposedly was the
main thing so what's the rest of it and
it turned out that I can't remember the
exact way around which is a long time
ago there was another 30% and there was
a 40% and one of them was implementing
EU directives M and the other was just
random things that the bureaucracy felt
needed to be done that weren't in the
Coalition agreement and they could have
been maintenance of existing programs or
whatever so it was a real you know I
open know that 70% of what we were doing
was not actually in the Coalition
agreement I find that horrendous the
fact that we have unelected bureaucrats
who the government are directing them to
enact policy a lot of the time and they
just look at and go no mate I don't
agree with it which is basically what
you're saying well and the other thing
that was really interesting was the
process that they use so I just
mentioned this the the the letter
writing and and they actually there's a
phrase for I don't by the way this is
like maybe it's all changed maybe it's
all being sorted
out this is in a sense it was my
experience ancient history you could say
know over 10 years ago um and they C the
phrase that was used was WR round I'll
and so ad Min let's we'll do a right
round you you write a letter that goes
round and it's not the whole cabinets
cabinet committees that's the sort of
mechanism for how policy gets made and
again people might think well policy is
made in Parliament and we have
legislation that goes through part
that's true but most policy that
actually affects you and affects people
in the daily in their daily lives that's
sort of it's not it's not legis it's not
new legislation it's just the
administration of government and so
that's how they there's this thing right
round and when we looked at that process
it was amazing because it was just it's
it's it's it's just almost a sort of
definition of of what you might imagine
as sort of paper pushing bureaucracy
where it's literally sort of paper I
mean it's emailed now but it's of
documents long documents many of them
and it's a covering letter I'm the
minister for whatever here's my I want
to do this and it's sent round to all
the the other members of the committee
and it turned out that the rules were
these they had 48 hours to
respond and if there was no response
that was considered to be
agreement and so it was this absolute
kind of bureaucratic racket of churning
out this stuff that no one has time to
read and no one and also there's an
incentive not to respond why because if
you don't mess up your colleague's thing
that means when you want to do something
they let it pass so basically everything
gets passed all the time there's no
objection and and the lack of objection
is taken as approval so it's an amazing
process That's How Stuff got done and it
very interesting I remember at the Time
Michael Gove who was education secretary
at the time he was the only one that
that seemed to read the stuff and that's
comforting right no and and object and
and sort of step in and say sorry I
don't agree with that I remember what
there was one examp example which
was what was it I was it and somebody
I'm sorry I can't read it was like it
was someone one of the cabinet ministers
proposed that every government
building would have to have would have
to develop in consultation with State
you know the usual jargon and publish a
suicide prevention strategy for people
who were you know potentially committing
suicide from their building like you
know like just the sort of classic thing
that and you may say who cares whatever
but all this stuff just takes up time
and it accumulates and whatever and and
and I remember say no I why should we do
that I don't agree with this you know so
he would be you know he would challenge
it but mostly the culture was not to
challenge it and you had 48 hours and
that was considered approval so like we
tried to kind of put some spokes in the
wheels of this machine turning around so
for example we extended the period to
like I think six days and then we also
tried to create a form um I don't even
know whether however this along this
lasted which was to just as a kind of
nudge to make them think that about
about it which was to to sort of sign
off does this this is the part of the
Coalition agreement that this proposal
is implementing just as a kind of to
make them realize that's what they're
supposed to be doing but in the end none
of this really m i mean you can't slow
it down that's why you know I was much
mocked and derided for this but my
conclusion um and and especially from
another another little exercise we did
which was cutting red tape you know
every government comes in and they say
we're going to cut red tape there too
much red tape cut the bureau slash
bureaucracy and none of them do like
it's just been the story it just gets
worse and worse and worse red tape
bureaucracy and it's easy to issue this
stuff but when you're a business trying
to implement it it's a nightmare it
makes you life of misery waste time and
money and gives you a headache and it's
it's just you know ridiculous so we
wanted to do something about that so we
had this kind of approach to it which
was rather than than going in like every
previous government and say well let's
try and find the things that we want to
cut why don't we have a different kind
of mindset which is let's review let's
look at everything and and choose the
ones we want to keep and assume that
everything else is gone just as a kind
of so you set the default that less
regulation and I just remember the first
meeting um I just thought we we we're
sunk because it was they divided all the
regulations on the books like tens of
thousands I think it was like maybe
29,000 sets of regulations they went
through diligently and put them into we
had different categories you know
consumer protection environmental
whatever and we had different and we had
a process for each one and we had the
meeting uh and I think we started with
consumer protection it was in Oliver
lewin's office I believe maybe for yeah
Oliver Lewin and we all sat around the
table and the and the officials from
that department came in with their sort
of document which was here you know with
the list of all the different
regulations and it was supposed to be
colorcoded for the ones we're keeping
and the ones we we we think we can get
rid of and I remember looking at them
and most of them were I can't remember
which way it was round red or green I
said oh so these are the ones that we're
getting rid of no no no that's what
we're keeping there's like two or three
that they felt we could get rid of so I
just thought okay let's go through it so
we went through and like I remember we
had almost the entire meeting just on
one one thing which I remember what it
was it was cuz it was just I just
thought I can't believe this it was uh
regulations about flammable pajamas
yeah and it was it's specific regulation
about flam with jum and I think it was
it was either men's or women's I can't
remember and and I said well why can't
this be covered in a general duty of we
had this long conversation about it and
I remember the official from the
Department of is it trade and I can't
remember who whatever it was said well
actually we had like half an hour
discussion just on that whether we could
whether we really just on pajamas and it
was one gender it was either male or I
guess today you'd have to have a that
wouldn't even be you couldn't even have
that conversation about male or female
pajamas too triggering but um but it was
it was at the end of this whole
discussion about either male or female
pajamas the official I never forget it
said well actually to the extent that
there is an interest in this from the
public I think the pressure would be to
equalize it and to add regulations for
female pajamas or whatever and honestly
we had this whole conversation about FL
the flapping of pajam and going in front
of a it was mad it was like a parody and
with that was the first meeting and I
just thought with this is it they they
know how to sort of grind you down and
the P there's always more of them than
there are of you and they can always
generate more paper and you'll never win
this battle and that's when I came to
the conclusion that the only way that
you would actually do what all these
governments promise which is to have
less regulation decentralized power and
so on is to massively reduce the number
of civil servants that's the only way
and so that led to a whole process which
was paraded in the me in the media about
me wanting to fire most of the civil
service but kind of Yes actually because
in not because they're doing a bad job
but because actually it shouldn't be so
centralized you shouldn't have this
giant bureaucracy of of just this the
tentacles reaching into every single
aspect of life it just feeds on itself
even if they got good intentions which
they do I'm not you know doubting their
in each individual person that they're
bad you I'm not saying they're bad
people with bad intentions just the
cumulative effect is just this nightmare
for for people and businesses and
society as a whole Steve you're really
uh Smiley and happy you you live in in
California of course you are but as I
listen to you as someone who lives in
the UK yes I'm furious well I
think you should be actually because
this is why okay espe especially the
last few years I as you said I'm here in
California I'm focused on not just us
politics actually California politics
and California you know we we're we're
the fifth big we're a bigger economy
than the UK and there's a lot going
wrong in California to to fix do you
know what I mean so it's like a big big
thing and that's what I'm focused on but
you know I obviously keep an eye on on
UK politics and it seems to me that
things are really stuck that's what it
feels like like for years now you've and
I don't want to weigh in too strongly
cuz I don't follow it closely and so I
may be getting things wrong but um it
does feel like you just have one prime
minister after another and it's all like
what's actually happening I mean what
you know where's the energy it just
feels very stuck nothing really gets
solved some of the problems seem to get
worse rather than better you know and I
think a lot of it is to do with this
fact that the Machinery of government
The Bu is really broken and
acknowledging that I would imagine that
a lot of civil servants are very
leftwing or left leaning again nothing
wrong with that if those are your
political opinions fair enough but the
problem comes when you see yourself as a
protector or a guardian of the UK and
someone comes in with a policy that they
deem to be right-wing and you say you're
not going going to enact it then what
you were doing is subverting the will of
the people who have elected that
government that's exactly right and
that's what Blair felt I mean he you
know he said that um and so I think he
said it publicly I don't think I'm
revealing anything sort of you know
greatly confidential but it's exactly
what you say because that's the theory
and and the the theory of governance is
that the politicians are elected by the
people and the and the and the
bureaucracy Faithfully implements what
they do but that's if that's not the
culture and and again I don't think it's
even necessarily that they they they may
not even be aware that that's what
they're doing but there's this sense of
it's almost grandiosity I think that
like well you know we we we've been here
we know how it works you can't possibly
do that there's definitely a lot of that
and you so you could you were known as a
bit of a renegade you know You' put
you'd come you turn up a Downing Street
in your shorts and all of that right so
you have a go at cutting the number of
civil servants how did that go well look
I mean I'll just say a few things which
is first of all I was only there for 2
years um and so I was there from 2010 to
2012 secondly I've you know looking back
on it I think I went about that job in a
hopelessly unprofessional manner to be
perfectly honest with you in the sense
that I or or you could say naive I don't
know which way you know but now having
started a business here and taught at
Stanford at this great organization
called the D School The Institute of
Design which really tells teaches you a
methodology of how you make change
happen how you how you in
so I've learned a lot about how you do
that and I think we went about it I went
about it as a bit of a bull in the china
shop to be honest and so I definitely
don't want anyone to think that this is
some great story of a thwarted hero and
a terrible you know I I I think that I
could have approached it much better um
but it I don't think anything happened I
mean I I I remember um to be perfectly
honest I think that we we ended up in
this Pro there there's Francis mud was
the minister and this process the civil
service reform process and you know it
was just a lot of meetings and
everyone's saying the right thing but in
the end like as I said I I came to the
conclusion that it's it's it does
reforming it isn't the answer you have
to cut it and there was no appetite to
do that at all like zero and in fact
some of the Francis M was very good and
there were some real
successes of of of what we did there
which he led um for example I mean know
people maybe not that interested in it
but the government digital service was
actually really good and and they
automated a lot of of things and saved a
bit of money and made made interacting
with the government of certain things
like renewing a passport I think you
know stuff like that better and and
actually that is seen as a model for the
world you know I've talked to people
here in America who think that's amazing
what what that what happened there so it
wasn't all bad but I think that
fundamental you know um
culture arrogance
really um that this is the machine and
this is how it has to operate I don't
think that was affected at all I I don't
think there was any reduction in
headcount Maybe I'm Wrong maybe they've
done it subsequently I don't think
so we'll be back with our guest in a
minute but first we wanted to quickly
tell you about our partners give send go
if you need to Crown fund but don't want
to hand over your money to faces big
Tech corporations then we recommend
using GIF and go GIF and go is a leading
crowdfunding website where thousands of
people in the US the UK Australia and
Canada raise funds for anything from
business ventures and medical expenses
to personal needs churches and funeral
costs on Gib and go you can raise money
for whatever you need we've met the
people at gifs and go and we can tell
you that they're absolutely aligned with
trigonometry on our approach to free
speech they've proved time and again
they won't cave to the Mob they don't
just talk the talk they walk the walk
unlike other big Tech companies and
that's why we are proud to partner with
them they like us believe that with
openness and honesty will create more
understanding and ultimately more
Harmony in the world GI and go is
absolutely free to use with other
crowdfunding sites you'll pay between 5
and 10% of the money you raise gifs and
go charges nothing at all to use their
platform they believe you should be able
to keep all the money you raise starting
a campaign on giv sango is easy and
intuitive go to giv sang go.com today
that's give send go.com to start raising
money for whatever is important to you
and now back to the
interview let's look at a subject like
illegal immigration yeah which is very
contentious you know and there's going
to be people on the left who look at it
through a particularly should we say a
moral lens and all the rest of it and
I'm looking at successive home
secretaries talking tough but ultimately
failing to curb illegal immigrant
yeah do you think this is the reason
why I think it's that they I think it's
not the only reason why it's part of it
and it's also the but what I don't
understand by the way is why this hasn't
been solved since leaving the EU I mean
that's like one of the main arguments so
I I truly don't understand why it's
still an issue in the sense that the
whole argument was we have control of
our borders so we don't need to worry
about I mean the argument before was
well we can't do anything about this
because they're using Asylum as the
entry point as the justification and you
can't do anything about that because
they're the international Court of Human
Rights or whatever there's a whole sort
of network of laws International laws
and with our hands are tied that you
heard that a lot and and someone like
Michael Howard who's very unpopular in
some ways very much admired by others
but he you know he he was very tough on
crime as a Home Secretary and tried to
do stuff and was very frustrated by all
this stuff that they had to deal with I
mean thought the whole point of the of
leaving the EU was that that was
something that you could then take
control of and it seems to me that they
haven't really pursued that aggressively
enough I don't maybe they've got a good
answer as to why not I think that the
it's that and and and and but I think
the current from what I can tell the
current Home Secretary seems to be the
most prepared to be unpopular in
confronting these things probably since
Michael Howard um so maybe she'll coin
Steve is is that unpopular as she may be
that's that's the main achievement that
she's generated has actually made
anything change yeah and by the way my
sense is she's genuinely trying yeah so
the question for us and that's why I
said it's infuriating hearing you say
because ultimately whether I agree with
the Kum house secretary or disagree the
idea of democracy is that we vote for a
government and that government then goes
and implements the things that we vote
for now
of course that isn't what always happens
we all accept that but immigration is a
very good example of this because it is
an issue on which the same promise is
made by success I know it's amazing and
then nothing gets done yeah and and
again the the why is it important look
the David Cameron used to put this I
think maybe he got it from Michael how
but um because he worked for Michael how
which is the it's people are generally
Pro immigration right they're you know
I'm the beneficiary of immigration you
know like we all are we all right and so
and I always said twice over you know my
family from Hungary to the UK now here I
am I'm a new American citizen and Etc so
very much pro-immigration but and I
think most people are but only if they
get a sense that it's controlled that
there's a sort of just as and that it's
fair fair there fairness exactly that
there's it's it's a reasonable system
and it's fair and controlled and the
minute that you lose control that
actually generates the ex L what you
don't want racism and xenophobia and all
the things you don't want because it
kind of naturally spills out when when
people feel that it's all just chaos and
and and not properly managed so there's
a really it's really important to get a
grip of it and the fact that successive
governments haven't I agree I I think
it's and it's totally reasonable to be
furious about it because either don't
make the promise and just say sorry
there's nothing we can do right this is
just the modern world I mean look some
by the way that's basically what's going
on here here in America where there not
there's not really any attempt to stop
migration I mean there they they barely
even pretend to try and it's all well
the root causes and there's lots of
violence and gangs in so to interrupt
you're in politics C can you explain to
the ordinary person how that's possible
because you and I are both old enough to
remember when Barack Obama was talking
tougher than Donald Trump on immigration
there was a moment like yesterday when
everybody agreed that countries need
borders People Like Us first generation
immigrants second generation immigrants
everybody understood that countries need
to control immigration and in the West
in both countries yours and ours now we
keep voting for governments and they
don't do it and a lot of people are now
going to the you know it's the globalist
conspiracy whatever because what how
else can you explain this yeah it's to I
mean look and it's it's exactly right
that they and and you know by the way
not just I mean there's there's some
amazing video actually that I saw I for
Nancy Pelosi who was the leader of the
Democrats in the House of
Representatives revered figure uh on the
Democrats she's from California from San
Francisco and um there's this amazing
video of her from the '90s talking about
in in terms that would
be like if Trump said it would be you
wouldn't even believe he'd said it it
sound so kind of you know
anti-immigration where she's talking
about did you know that you know what
like 10% of the babies born in San
Francisco hospitals are the children of
illegal immigrants we can't have this
drain on us you know amazing just that's
Nancy Pelosi the Hillary Clinton and all
these people totally in favor of a
border wall not that long ago voted for
it many of them in Congress you know so
it's totally
changed
the bill before us will certainly do
some good it will authorize some badly
needed funding for better fences and
better security along our borders the
fence is now basically complete maybe
they'll need a
moat maybe they want alligators in the
moat secure our borders with technology
Personnel uh physical barriers if
necessary in some places we will not
build a wall instead we will build an
economy where everyone who wants a good
job can get one I voted for offense I
voted like unlike most Democrats some of
you won like it I voted for 700 M 10 let
me tell you something folks people are
driving across that border with tons
tons hear me
tons of everything from by products from
methampetamine to cocaine to heroin it's
all coming up through corrupt Mexico the
impulse is the Hunker down shut the
gates build walls exit at this
moment is precisely the wrong answer
former presidents have said to him that
they wish that they had built a wall do
you recall President Obama ever saying
that come on construction of a 630m
border fence create a significant
barrier to Illegal immigration on our
southern land border all along the
president saying well I'll do DACA and
dreamers in return for the wall he's got
it president Trump if you want to open
the government you must abandon the
wall I think it's part of the general
which you cover so well and you know
much better than I do that General kind
of shift to this really superficial
virtue signaling kind of mindset on the
left which is oh we mustn't say anything
that comes across as racist or mean or
xenophobic and if you have control then
people who are suffering will be denied
that you know that whole mindset um I
think has taken over and and it's just
this culture of it's a sort of lack of
seriousness about the issues it's just
saying yeah we can just be nice to
everyone um of course we want to be nice
to everyone in our lives we want to be
nice we don't treat people with respect
and be kind and so on that's true but
it's not you know you have a situ I
don't again can't speak to the the
British situation but here here in
America like total chaos in in border
states places like Texas and Arizona now
you have new the mayor of New York Eric
Adams saying the the ju just a few th
tens of thousands of illegal migrants
arriving in New York being taken there
on buses tens of thousands will destroy
that's his word will destroy New York
City there is 1.7 million actually 1.8
million
last year illegal immigrants that are
called gotway where they they're not
even recorded that's one that 1.8
million he's saying tens of thousands
will destroy New York City you have
places like there's a city in AR Yuma
Arizona
250,000 migrants in that one city that's
more than I think the population's only
about 990,000 you know it's it's
completely overwhelming and that it's
just a lack of seriousness just to say
well we can't put anything in the way
because it's I mean I think it's this
obsession with not wanting to appear in
any way racist or mean about anything do
again I'm like you I never thought I'd
say these words I'm just listening to
this Steve and I'm getting so angry it's
an abdication of respons you can tell we
don't live in California no one here is
angry no matter what's going on you're
just happy cuz it's nice you know I mean
look the thing is I I'll tell you that
the whether it is but there's a lot I I
know you talk about the UK but there's a
lot to be angry about him and the if you
walk around and anyone who comes here
and you know will see it's do you know
that phrase it was JK galra The
Economist wrote that very famous phrase
about C in critiquing capitalism talking
about um private affluence public
squalor yeah that's basic what you have
in California now because you've got
this incredible wealth and squalor and I
think people are actually getting more
and more angry about it but still yeah
no no there's something that's actually
something I want to talk to you about
but we move on to that later the thing
look I get very angry I'm very angry
about this and I'm also very worried
because this is what the problem is
Steve democracy if what you're saying is
true and I believe it's true because it
makes sense then the reality is
democracy no longer works because you're
electing people who are essentially
powerless because of these bureaucrats
which then means that people lose their
faith in the democratic system which
means that our entire way of governing
no longer works
which means that something serious and
drastic is going to happen because
people are going to get more and more
angry and deservedly so I really agree
with with a lot of that analysis which
is that there's this building rage and
it's coming out in all sorts of
unpleasant ways and sometimes
constructive ways but generally there's
a sort of real and and people talk about
polarization and and whatever but
there's a there's just a lot of anger
because of basic things going wrong for
people and so you look at um I don't
again I I can't speak to the exact UK
experience but you know like everyone
sort of you know politicians saying
everything's great the econom is great
we're doing this growth whatever and
like everything's more expensive I can't
afford this not you know it's just a ba
basic things of daily life are a hassle
expensive it's a nightmare you know
those are the sort of realities for
people and I do agree that the Machinery
of government feels completely
inadequate and and in terms of the you
know delivering what it's supposed to do
which is translate these proom it's easy
to write the prom I've written lots of
speeches and things you can write the
nice things and they sound attractive
but I think if you keep going down this
cycle of making the promise and not
delivering then you're just going to get
more and more rage I mean one one one
conclusion I came to was which I feel
very strongly about decentralizing power
because I think that that is the way to
make to really deal with this problem
which is that actually one way to deal
with the problem which is that if you
put like truly decentralize it so that
you can feel that your Vote or your
decision making really affects your life
so I was really interested in the idea
of neighborhoods as the as a really you
know a sort of different unit of govern
not just local councils if you look at
local councils I remember going through
this in some of the biggest councils in
London you know the the burrowers
they're like like millions of people
nearly you know some of them maybe more
I can't remember exactly but you know a
lot of people really big so that's big
government I mean that's that's not
close to the people so really giving
control over what goes on in your
neighborhood and I think it's a it's an
interesting idea but anytime you talk
like this they dismiss it as
you know Airy fairy oh that won't work
but it's not as if their version is
working so I think that that we've got
to try and solve it and I think that
idea of put I mean this you know I'm I'm
sort of feeling frustrated now because
this was really a big part of the idea
of the going back to where we started
the Coalition agreement if you read that
document it's full of stuff about
decentralizing power putting putting
agency and budgets in the hands of
people and neighborhoods we wanted to
have Mayors every elected mayor so that
you could have a a figure of
accountability not just for a big city
but you know like in France they have a
lot more decentralization and so you
know there was there's this vision of of
actually quite a radical reengineering
of government that basically never
happened yeah and it's worrying as well
because you look at the States where
people are frustrated and are
angry and that led to Trump yes exactly
you know and you know and the Liberals
will you know ring their hands and
they'll say this is awful this is
disgusting how can this man have got to
power this is because people are racist
stupid no go no because they don't feel
that they're being represented well you
could say even more extraordinary
actually you could say
after everything that's happened January
the 6th everything else and being
indicted or what it 91 counts and all
this they threw everything at him and
all the abuse and the entire media all
the establishment piling on for years
and now he's the front runner for the
nomination and and as a there was the
poll the other week a 10-point lead over
Biden a 10-point lead so you think well
all these people that have just been
it's Unthinkable you can't have
like something really serious is going
wrong when you get um that kind of you
know result in public okay it's a poll
and who knows what's going to happen in
the election next year but you're
totally right it really is driving a lot
of that rage and on the on the on the
left as well so in 2016 it was very here
in America it's very interesting because
you had Trump but you also had Bernie
Sanders who's doing very well and and
came out of nowhere when he when he
announced his campaign people thought it
was a joke some crotchety old Senator
that no one had ever heard of and
suddenly he's leading a movement young
people are super enthusiastic you know
the biggest Grassroots movement anyone's
ever seen massive you know amounts of
small dollar donations you know Bernie
Sanders was
really a really big and still is really
big phenomenon your point about uh Trump
uh and the frustrations is interesting
because um Michael malice who a recent
guest of on on that show one of the
things he was talking about is how the
moment what he calls the corporate press
the mainstream media attack somebody as
being wrong bad and evil yeah they go
that now their reputation going it's
really interesting it's a bit like so
it's so funny I was the other day I was
doing a talk somewhere um oh yeah that's
where and and I was I was talking about
how here in California that well I refer
I was referring back to learning
economics um at Oxford and there was the
I've forgotten nearly everything but I'm
not particularly academic person but I
do remember this one thing called a gif
in good and the gifing good confounds
the normal laws of Economics so like the
the normally it's like there's a demand
curve I think they that goes up upward
sloping demand curve so the price goes
up the demand goes down whatever and
it's exactly the opposite the cheaper
something is with the GI and good the
fewer the people don't want it because
they think there's something wrong with
it or the more expensive it get becomes
more popular and it's the same with that
you know the more they attack some the
the press the mainstream press attacks
someone the more support they get
I was talking about the problems in
California where it seems to be the more
that they focus on a problem and the
more money they spend on the problem the
worse it seems to get that's definitely
what we've had with homelessness weighs
just all around and billions and
billions of dollars keep being spent um
and what does that happen Steve I mean
we had Tom Billy on the show very
recently who who who he's sort of like
people aren't thinking about the end
result they're thinking often about what
sounds right what makes them feel good
Etc and they're not Tes they're not
going well let's have a go at this's put
some money into this let's see what the
result is and if the result isn't what
we want let's try something else and
whatever yeah but you know everyone we
speak to here yeah left and right yeah
recognizes that there's problem because
it's kind of hard not to see it yes
right yeah and this is one of the
richest not just States one of the
richest countries in the world yeah I
mean there's an really I mean if you
look at the income the the kind of
income per head 49 out of 50 states
within America are richer than the UK uh
it's you know like there's only one
that's poor I don't it's either Alabama
or Mississippi I don't know which one I
think it's Miss no I think actually
mississipp I think is it I yeah 49 so
you know it's it's exactly as you say
it's very wealthy well I've uh let let's
just there's two there's just think
about the problem that first of all this
way right there's the
stock and the flow and that's always
quite an interesting way of thinking
about a problem so you've got the stock
of people the people who are currently
experiencing homelessness who are on the
streets and then you've got the the FL
the pipeline as of people who who become
homeless the stock issue is in a way in
a way it's it's almost a sort of
simplifix because it's you can the truth
is that most of the people living on the
streets 80% or more um have either one
or both of the me mental health issues
or addiction even if they weren't when
they arrived when they became homeless
that's the typical pattern it's really
tragic like you become homeless you may
and there's many many stories of of
people you would say normal people
nothing wrong with their and then they
get they because their life is very
precarious and they lose their job and
then they can't pay rent and then they
live on people's couches for a bit and
then that run they run out of favors
then they live in the car and then they
can't afford the car and then they live
on that that that that is very common
and even if you're not you're totally
fine just poor um and you don't have any
kind of drug use within weeks sometimes
of being on the streets you're you're a
target for drug dealing and crime and
this absolute stress of it literally
sends you crazy so that's sadly what
often happens so you got roughly 80%
mental health drug addiction
the problem is you've got you've got
laws in place that stop you actually
dealing with that for example there's a
2016 bill passed I think it's SB 1380 if
you want to someone can look it up
passed by the California legislature
that makes it it's well the the name of
it was housing
first what it does is Implement an idea
which sounds nice and plausible which is
the most important thing for someone
who's homeless is to get them into
housing and then can deal with their
problems but you're never going to deal
with their problems if they're on the
street that sounds plausible but what's
contained in housing first is a ban on
any state it's illegal for any state
program any program that takes money
from the from the California government
to require
sobriety so you can't deal with the drug
addiction it's actually illegal to solve
the problem so what you see over and
over again is people are homeless going
into programs and this is where the you
know 20 billion spent in the last few
years only for the numbers to go up and
they're not and they're still addicted
to drugs people who I mean I've been to
Venice and talked to people working on
the streets with homeless people it's
like they literally say the language
they use they have a second home so we
give them shelter accommodation by the
way for other reasons costing $800,000
per unit that's a separate thing what in
La $800,000 per
unit that's let's not get into that and
they're in the shelter but there's no
requirement to stop using drugs they're
not in any kind of treatment program for
drugs it's illegal to require them to be
sober and so you've got these shelters
that are just people sharing drugs using
drug drug and then they go out and they
often keep a place on the streets this
is what I was told from people who work
there to get the drugs or deal drugs so
that's one thing secondly on Mental
Health um because of previous policies
that were aimed at dealing with what was
considered to be kind of you know
nightmare old mental health institutions
put people into the community and so on
shut down a lot of mental health
hospitals then they always site One Flew
Over the cooku neest we don't want that
kind of thing anymore I'm sure we don't
but what you've got now is a massive
lack of capacity for mental health
treatment there's a rule um this is a
federal rule that you can't have more
than 16 beds in a mental health capacity
so that means you just don't have the
ability to treat people on the scale
that you need you have hundreds of
thousands of people mentally ill drug
drug addicted to drugs and they're just
not getting the treatment and then on
top of that you've had uh uh this is the
the one that's probably done the most
damage is a ruling from the ninth
circuit called the Boise ruling which is
Boise in Idaho and it's a particular
case the ninth circuit covers the
western states so California Washington
Oregon and so on and the ruling it was a
particular case that was brought when
the city tried to remove someone into
shelter who was on the streets and the
ruling was you can't do that it's it's
it's it's violating their rights um
unless the city can provide shelter for
everyone not just for that person but
for every single person who's on the
streets that's the ruling then you have
homeless Advocates and nonprofits who
make a lot of money out of this whole
thing blocking temporary shelter for
example a tent or B they know the only
thing that that that we'll allow is
permanent H supported housing and so you
get into this cycle of the only way you
can get them off the street is if you
solve the problem in a big way but youve
got the you've got groups locally saying
we we're going to stand we're going to
oppose it so it's just been stuck for
years and it's just a total mess but all
of it is solvable if you have the right
attitude to just cut through and say
sorry that's ridiculous you know it's
inhumane to leave people on the street
this is the thing that really is the
core of it isn't it Steve which is we
are pretending to be compassionate
exactly instead of actually being
Compass because leaving somebody on the
street instead of being in a mental
health hospital because you saw a movie
Once that's not compassionate it's the
opp exactly right exactly and saying
well we can't you know I mean there
someone who's written really well about
all this and studied it very closely
Michael schelberg
and so he I mean he introduced me to
this phrase oh gosh what was it oh yes
um that if you
argue that sub you know like if
someone's addicted to drugs you know you
should they should get off drugs and get
back on a pathway to a a sort of
reasonable life where they can earn a
living and support themselves and so on
and live on their own independently that
that is that's anti Euphoria that's the
phrase now that that's being used anti
Euphoria people have a right to Euphoria
and who are you to tell them but that's
so stupid because it's also cruel that
your word because it's like that's not a
choice that's it's it's you're an
addict yeah the reason you take drugs is
not to experience Euphoria for those
people especially well those people it's
definitely the reason I take anyway
speak for
yourself but yeah true but lying on the
street injecting a massive difference
between addiction this is like it's it's
an illness you know and and and so it
needs treatment and you that's the
compassionate thing to do and to require
treatment now I should say just for you
know factual context just this the week
that we are recording this interview the
California legislature just passed a
bill that would make it slightly easier
to force people to enter treatment it's
it's an update of the conservatorship
laws that that that you can you can
actually act and and put someone into
treatment against their will but there's
so many other constraints there are so
many existing laws that block that for
example the provision of the mental
health capacity that is very you know
unlikely to me it seems unlikely to me
it's going to make any difference but
it's the core point is exactly that it's
this idea of compassion and I think that
it's it's funny I've thinking about that
a lot because it's it's a it's this sort
of softness it's this almost this
ideology of appeasement and I always
think about it in the in the context of
you know raising kids like it's it's as
if we're doing exactly the opposite of
what normal people would think is how
you just behave in in normal life the
way you raise your kids in other words
you incentivize people for doing the
wrong thing and you punish them for
doing the right thing and that seems to
be true in so many different areas and
so when you've got someone clearly doing
something and extends to crime and so on
and it's this this desire to be liked to
be to to you know to look nice and and
look compassionate it's exactly right
it's so profound that you know and that
is exactly what's driving the the the
immigration situation it's like we don't
want to look mean and if we turn people
away then we're mean but it how
compassionate is it to see what you've
incentivized there unbelievable
trafficking of people child trafficking
children raped on the journey through
Central America to get to the border you
know criminal gangs um enriched people
drowning in the Rio Grand every day you
know what what's compassionate about
that it is completely disgusting but
it's done in the name of compassion I
think that is basically the the central
kind of theme of of almost everything
that's going
wrong we'll get back to the episode in a
minute but first we want to talk to you
about ag1 if you're a longtime fan you
might know we've been drinking ag1 for
over a year now to stay stay healthy and
Stave off illness in preparation for
whenever our schedule gets really busy
when we use ag1 on our busy America
tours we've found that we feel a real
difference to our energy levels and our
ability to focus so my concentration
span has gone from 2 seconds to 12
that's because ag1 is a foundational
nutrition supplement that supports your
body's Universal needs like gut
optimization Stress Management and
immune support since 2010 ag1 has led
the future of foundational nutrition
continuously refine in their formula to
create a smarter better way to elevate
your Baseline Health even the
trigonometry team here have started
drinking ag1 and they love it our
producer was just telling me about how
much more energetic he feels that his
stress levels feel more manageable now
and because of this we're hoping he'll
hit his deadlines for the first time in
over 5 years ag1 is the supplement I
trust to support my daily health and
that's why they've been a trigonometry
partner for so long now if you want to
take ownership of your health it starts
with ag1 try ag1 and get a free one-year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 and five free
ag1 travel packs with your first
purchase go to drink a1.com
trigonometry that's drink a1.com
trigonometry check it out and now back
to the
interview and do you think the problem
is as well is the fact that you have
these people who are constantly up for
election every four years so they want
to appear compassionate they don't want
to appear to be the bad guy so what do
you do you're talking about the UK or
here just everywhere yeah I mean there's
there's there's a lot lot to talk about
if we're talking about here but first of
all in the in in that you've got so many
different layers of government and and
in and a lot of them are elected every
two years wow so and one of the issues
is actually The Districts The
gerrymandering of districts so fewer and
fewer districts certainly in the federal
level are competitive so there's no need
to appeal to a broader Electra it's just
your core supporters and it's a little I
think there's an analogy with what's
happening in media to a certain extent
youve got that phenomenon of audience
capture where you sort of because of the
fragmentation and you build an audience
and you serve the audience and you just
go down that road and you become more
and more kind of boiled down to the
essence rather than appealing to a
broader audience that's happening with a
lot of politics actually so it's not
just the so and for some audiences they
don't want the compassion they want you
know tough but sometimes that can be
wrong as well you know it's just a that
basic Common Sense pragmatic like hey
what's going on how do we solve the
problem it's just really seems to be
disappearing and by doing this
compassionate approach or false
compassion whatever we want to call it
you're driving more and more people to
that gesture that you just me exactly
it's it's it's the fury cuz nothing
changes exactly and so what what I worry
about Steve is things are looking not
great to put it mildly where are we
going to be in 10 years well I don't you
tell me I mean what do you think like if
I mean I've just been again we're taping
this just soon after the um party
conferences in the UK I don't know when
people may be watching but um there was
I don't know does K dmer offer people
hope I haven't been following it well
this is the thing St is he the great I
mean Tony BL I remember the you know was
like really exciting actually well this
is the point right whenever we have a
lefty on the show we say are you excited
about Kia stama no whenever we have a
right-wing on the show are you excited
about the conservative government no
interesting no one is excited about the
people that are supposedly representing
them because of the things that we've
discussed which is we've kind of you
know you can only press a button so many
times without the light coming on that
you stay excited about the possib you
know what's interesting about that that
makes me think I tell you who's who is
excited here and I saw thousands of them
uh just a couple of weeks ago at the
California Republican convention Trump
he whatever whatever you think his
supporters are incredibly excited
because they believe that he is going to
you know they
remember that times were better and you
didn't have this chaos at the boorder
I'm just telling you what they say I
mean people can ch it but that's their
memory um the economy was better we were
earning more we didn't have inflation we
didn't have these wars we didn't have
Putin invading Ukraine and terrorist
Rampage around the middle we didn't have
all of that we had peace and we had
prosperity and the Border was Secure and
things were kind of good was it I'm just
not well it wasn't it hasn't been for
for decades but it's what you didn't see
the numbers you see now yeah no not not
even close I mean I was just looking at
some data on the uh the numbers of
people apprehended these is just the
ones they know about at the southern
Border in America who were on the FBI's
terrorist watch list and and it's just
incredibly clear you look at 20 I mean I
don't have the exact numbers to but this
is the scale is completely right what
I'm about to tell you first year of
trump
20176 2018 4
20190 there were two zeros maybe 2020 Z
first year of Biden 21 you
53 2022 174 you know like just a massive
change and
so it's true that it wasn't it wasn't
secure but it was a lot better than it
is now anyway I'm not even saying you
know I'm not like endorsing one way the
other or saying what I'm not validating
necessarily what those Trump supporters
think I'm just pointing out that that's
what they say they're excited and they
really are excited and they
believe in
him and it's interesting when you talk
to them it's interesting to get back to
what you're saying you know throughout
as a theme was when you asked them and I
have done this like why why because
what's really interesting about the
Trump phenomenon is is the broad range
of the support which perhaps isn't kind
of captured in some of the caricatures
which is you've got a massive um shift
in in the demographics of American
politics where the the for example the
Latino vote and here in California the
Latino vote is 40% of the the largest
group that makes complete sense to me in
in California you have 40% Latino 30%
white 15% Asian 5% black something like
that um and so the Latino vote shifting
each election with like 10% towards
Republicans and so and and and the Asian
vote as well so you got a lot more
racial diversity in in the Trump
Coalition and it's interesting that it
could you you've got people of all you
talk to workingclass a lot of
workingclass support you you talk to
wealthy people as well why do you
support Trump he G he gets things done
he he made promises and he got it done
he that's what they think now people may
dispute that but literally that's what
they think and so that kind of speaks to
a real desire for that that is the
number one thing that they say well of
course he got he delivered his promises
I mean they never made use that exact
term but like he's I mean I've heard it
many times we were just on vacation in
Alaska and there's some people there who
knew me from my TV thing we're just
chatting and and they were not your what
you might imagine as your sort of
typical Trump supporter um and you know
kind and and they they were and in fact
the the woman is a couple and the woman
was like she was not political at all
before Trump and in fact her family was
Democratic so if anything she was
Democratic and so I wasn't really
interested but then I saw him and I
thought you know this guy's really doing
what he said he said he'd do these
things and he's doing it and they're all
trying to stop him but he's doing it
it's really interesting that there was
this very kind of GS connection to to
the sort of delivery of promises well
this is the thing that I think people
have criticized Trump for which comes
back to the very beginning of our
conversation which is some people argue
he didn't deliver on some many of the
things that he promised and he would
argue and a lot of his supporters would
argue well the only reason he didn't
it's the Deep stay well there's a lot of
Truth to that I mean you could see that
um and I you know I I wasn't involved
particularly and I I there on the East
Coast on the west coast and I covered it
to a certain extent but it was
definitely true particularly at the
beginning I mean in in a way they had
the Tony Blair problem but like much
even much because they had no experience
he'd never done it before he says this
now he said I got there barely spent any
time in Washington I didn't know how it
worked and I hired all these people that
I was told to hire who who knew how it
all worked and it turns out they didn't
really agree with his policies and so he
had a a really overt campaign of
stopping him from doing stuff for
example on the border wall they didn't
agree with it um the trade policy the
the the the challenge to China you know
there there was a lot of and and I think
by the way this is one of the reasons
that I think I mean this is just amateur
psychology here but I I just think it's
one of the reasons that it's almost that
he was so kind of DED on um Twitter and
all the rest of it because he was so
frustrated like hang on a second I got
elected I had really simple
promises why why can't we just do it you
what all these people telling me I can't
or I should and and of course there's a
constitutional answer to that partly
which is that You' got separation of
powers you need Congress to pass laws
etc etc but even putting that aside
there was a lot of attempt to frustrate
him so but that argument about the Deep
state which is a phrase you know that
people can mock or whatever but it's
absolutely true that there's it's the
same as where we where we started out
that there's a a group a very entrenched
bureaucracy that just doesn't believe in
that has an ideology and it tends to be
more left I think it's I think it's more
politicized here in America than it is
even in the UK I mean individually I
found this the civil servants in the UK
that I dealt with professional nice you
know they were like on some mission to
subvert the government
but and and I think they do try to be
you know
apolitical but you know you can't
totally put that aside but here I think
they really remember that they're all
drawn from Washington DC which is an
incredibly I think it's almost the most
democratic city in the country it's like
90% voted for Clinton or something like
that and they will live there they're
drawn from that
Community Steve I mean it's been a
pleasure we could literally talk for the
rest of the for for the rest of the day
but we've run out of time okay well I'm
sorry about that people should know that
I was late so the extent that um he's
really integrated into California time
anymore yeah I'm sorry about that no
it's absolutely fine our final question
is always the same what's the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be oh my gosh
um well the one thing we haven't talked
about at
all that I always think is the core to
Everything Is is Family actually I know
that sounds that's probably maybe you
were hoping for a more of a jokey answer
but I think that um it's
actually the single thing I always say
this that if if you know if if if we
could and I going say something that
sounds glib but it's really fundamental
which is if we could just get to a point
where every child is raised in a stable
loving home so many of the problems that
we we talk about government works on we
spend money on we raise taxes to spend
on and whatever would would just not
exist it's a really sort of Deep thing
and actually that is not something that
you can just that that you may just hope
for there are things we can do to make
that more likely like what well I mean
I've written about them in in my books
in more human and and in positive po
especially more human if people want to
check it out but for example well
there's a couple of things so
there's people assume assume that
parenting is something that is just
natural and comes easily and and so on
and actually that is not true and it's
incredibly hard and I'm a parent of two
kids and you just you know new are you a
parent no so it's it's really hard and
stressful I'm trying to get him to get
married what are you doing man exactly
no no but it's rewarding and joyful as
well of course everyone knows that but
it's also really hard and so you can
help people with that and and and and
actually sharing the you know there's a
whole kind of set of that I try to get
that going as a policy actually um but I
I think it's better done in the private
sector so one of my dreams was to start
a business that would offer kind of
parent coaching in a kind of supportive
aspirational way you know I think for
example we can work on that problem and
actually that would really do a lot to
you know just keep families together
because managing those stresses is
something that we can help with and
there's a stigma against getting help
for that which is ridiculous and I think
we can do something about it also if you
look at um the way in which particularly
you know in in in the more disadvantaged
communities less money more precarious
circumstances worse housing and so on
it's even harder and so a huge
proportion of those issues that you that
you end up dealing with and and a vast
proportion of government money ends up
being spent on you can deal with if you
you know there are really established
programs we try to get something going
the um what was it called the
um can't remember the something families
program you know and and it's it you
know giving really Hands-On help an an
early age here there's something um in
America called the um um parent nurse
partnership nurse parent partnership and
um and it's absolutely phenomenally
successful and you have a trained nurse
comes into the house or helps you with
basic things you know it just transforms
prospects for families and kids so it's
and there's other things there's Lo
there's loads of absolutely positive
practical things you could do that would
save so much money but again you sort of
well that's not as serious as you know
tax cuts or what you know what I mean
there's a sort of bias against that kind
of stuff it's a bit touchy feely and the
civil servants don't understand it by
the way I should now this is supposed to
be a short answer at the end wasn't it
I'm really sure no no it's um the I
would say the single best Civil Service
interaction I had was with someone in I
think the Department of Education and
she was and you find there these are
amazing people who are who kind of to a
certain extent maybe languishing because
no one's kind of paid attention to their
area before she was a real expert in
parenting and she and we worked on a
program to try and kind of stimulate
some private sector response and like
parenting coaching and stuff like that
she was amazing and I had such great um
interactions with her because she felt
really excited that someone was you know
engaged in in the thing that she really
was passionate about and knew really
expert in and so all I would say is when
it comes to family um it's worth paying
a lot of attention to and I don't think
the political system does because it's
not as it's not as kind of dramatic as
some of the other things that get talked
about and argued about the whole time
but if we did pay more attention to it
and talk about it more I just think we
we'd have a completely different Society
Steve Hilton thank you very much thank
[Music]
you